WALKS IN -- WIDEMANALLEN.
THE PANTHERS RIGHT OUT IN
FRONT, COMING IN WITH A
BACK
BYRON --
ARMIA MOVES IN, THE PASS, THE
SHOT'S BLOCKED PRESSURE ON.
GIROUX  TO STEA
LUOSTARINEN  --PUTS IT RIGHT OV
SHELF WEAR
JUMBO  HE JUST TURNED
BECAUSE HE ANTICIPA HOFFMAN HAD
-- HERE'S A CHANCE AT RUNN
HUBERDEAU , GREAT MOVE TO PLAY
THAT PUCK . HE
FIRES AND SCORES AGAIN.
OVER THE GLOVED
HANDS OF JAKE ALLENAND UPSTAIRS
YOU SEE HOW MANY OTHER AND THEY
SCORE AGAIN.M GOING TO SHOW YOU
HAPPENED.
HERE'S GUD
PUT OUT IN FRONT, AND THEY
SCORE GET IT.E BACK.
SCORE!
HUBERDEAU IS GOT TWO ICE.
CLAUDE GIROUX
JAMMED UP BY EVANS.
EVANS WITH THE TAKE AWAY, EVANS
TRIED TO GET SCORES.
THAT IS A HUGE ONE FOR THE
PANTEMPTY
NETTERTHE BOARDS.